[Music]
while I having a clapping mood can we
give a round of applause for the
organizers in the MC MCS because they
were not supposed to be doing that and
they were amazing and it's the end of
the day so super Hardy one thank you so
I'm so very excited about this talk and
how the schedule worked out because we
started with her arts in the morning and
we're gonna end with our night so it's
sort of like bookcase took the we booked
he's JavaScript with art and I think
that's really exciting I'm Monica
I'm not Waldorf on Twitter in internet
places that is my cat I do like cats I'm
an engineer at Google on a team called
magenta in Google brain so I work with a
whole bunch of researchers with machine
learning and I'm gonna tell you a little
bit about that in a little bit because
first I'm gonna talk to you about my
favorite topping in the world myself if
you've ever heard about me it's probably
because I made something really dumb and
I put it on the internet and you played
with it because that's what I really
like doing I really like building silly
things and I kept calling them silly for
the blast like three or four years and I
realized it's not entirely clear what I
mean by silly because - you silly means
something else probably it might mean
that the thing that I make aren't
serious or aren't important I don't know
or I don't care about them and that's
not true everything that I make is like
my little darling I put a lot of time in
them sometimes it take me like six
months I love all of them whenever I put
them out there it stresses me out like
every good artist gives me anxiety
because you're gonna look at it and
judge it but silliness to me implies
that you can take it light heartedly you
could call it art but I don't art is the
word that I struggle with because I feel
like a society we sort of ruined the
word art when we refer to something as
art we have to judge it
everybody's been taught to like a look
at a painting and be like I couldn't
make that in my living room
is it really art and then you don't
enjoy it you like put on your judging
hat and you start hating on it and I
don't
want to be on the receiving end of that
and in particular I just want you to
have fun with them so this is why I call
them silly they're not art they're just
silly things that he can interact with
these are the kind of things that I make
this is called MIDI 32,000 and it
literally build cities out of rock and
roll if you think about a MIDI file
which is this abstract representation
for music MIDI files have different
instruments which you can think about
them as like rows of buildings like in
different places in your city and at
every point in time you play a note on
one of these instruments and the notes
are represented by pitches so at a point
in time you basically have a pitch which
is like the height of the building and
its length it's a duration so this is
how MIDI cities actually look like
cities MIDI cities got MIDI music
actually looks like cities and of course
you can play them and if the sound gods
work with us it should sound like this
[Music]
the great thing about this is that once
you understand that's what MIDI is like
you can start playing around with this
file you can throw away some of the rows
of the buildings you can increase the
density or decrease it between these
buildings and that makes a new song
[Music]
it's not a good song but that's fine not
all the music that we make is good to
look at a lot of radio stations out
there and we make a lot of garbage why
not make garbage with JavaScript why why
is that stopping us and I really like
this project it's my favorite thing that
I've ever made because it's not just
visual it's a really weird and possibly
useless music instrument that you can
play with and I like that it's silly
it's like the definition of my life um
the thing about making things I make
them because I like it but I make them
because making things is objectively
good there's a whole bunch of like
science research that shows that making
art actually helps you decrease your
cortisol levels it actually decreases
your stress and your anxiety if you
doodle while learning concepts you form
like different connections in the brain
and you learn things differently and it
helps you like reason through problems
making things is objectively good so I
make these things because it's
objectively good for me it's how I have
fun but in particular I make them so
that you can also make silly things with
me the things that I built aren't like
static art that you go and look at with
your eyeballs I make things where you
can click on them and you can make music
with them that demo that I showed you is
I'm glitch you can upload your own MIDI
files you can play with them you can
download them you can put them on
soundcloud and call it your new album do
whatever you want with them and these
are the kind of things that I like I
want to be able to in some way help you
with your creative process whether you
think you have won or not and sort of
extended and made it make a delightful
experience out of it and that's what
I've started calling generative delight
I used to call a generative art but
that's a term that already exists and
it's well defined and I kept like
[ __ ] around with the definition so I
stopped doing that and to me generative
delight is this idea that I put a bunch
of code out there and then you put a
little bit of your creative process in
it and then I throw in like a randomness
in the output and what we get out of it
is something that hopefully is you know
generated and also delightful generative
delight the first thing that I did are
on this topic I've been like working in
this area for it and I say working very
very broadly because everything I make
is ridiculous but
for three or four years and it's like
been getting better and worse at times
the first thing that I ever made was
emoji late which is a great and fun and
useless app where you upload an image
and it gets pixelated and it replaces
every pixel with an emoji excellent why
wouldn't you want that and I really like
it because obviously emoji but it's not
exactly a successful project for that
generally D'Lite idea because your
creative expression isn't really in
there like sure you pick what image
you're uploading but you can't really
control what emoji comes out of it it's
not something that I built in its like
picks the emoji that's closest to the
color of that pixel if you're having a
bad day and you don't want to see any
like people in it tough luck it module
eight doesn't care the other part that I
really did not like about this is that
that random delight isn't in there once
you look at this screen and I told you
what emoji lead does you know exactly
well not exactly but like you have a
very good idea if you upload an image of
a cat what that emoji lated cat is gonna
look like you're gonna pixelate it in
your mind and you're gonna put a bunch
of like emoji of that color that do like
that randomness isn't really there it's
like fairly deterministic so in order to
fix this because I was sort of in like
this slump of not making the things that
I wanted to do I introduced rules and if
you talk to any artists out there rules
are like crucial to anybody producing
anything because if the world is
literally your oyster you're not gonna
be able to produce something that's very
honed in and very specific and I find
the same thing happens in in any regular
in any like programming if you don't
have any rules the problem is really
complicated you can like pick anything
on like the server and the database and
your friend like a front-end framework
and your whatever you want in the
language and typescript in JavaScript
and if you have to make all of these
choices then you have less time to think
about well what should your application
do what is the experience you're trying
to communicate so the rules that I
introduced for basically that everything
that I made had to have emoji in it the
thing that it was gonna do is just
display emoji somehow to the user and
then once I figured that one out the
thing that I had to focus on was well
what are we gonna do with this emoji
what is this creative expression that I
have to do with emoji now that I work on
a team that makes music pretty much
everything that I build touches mini
files because that's the kind of thing
that that doesn't kind of rule that I
introduced right now so the next thing
that I built in this project was called
emoji garden which generates a random
Garden of emoji things you can control
are the size of the garden and the
density of snacks and visitors things
you can't control anything else
this ended up being a surprisingly
wildly popular project for it like the
three hours that it took to make top
highlight of my life Susan care the icon
designer tweeted about it and then I
died a little bit and I just went home
and celebrated Monica Lewinsky also
tweeted about it so weird parts of my
world coming together but ironically
this was also a failed project for me
because it again did not have this
creative expression of yours in it you
don't get to control anything you
basically like roll the dice and it
generates the garden for you maybe
carrots killed your family and you would
prefer no carrots in your garden tough
luck would you garden really doesn't
care so this was a bit of a bummer cuz I
was like well I made something really
fun but I didn't make the thing that I
wanted to do again but it turned out to
be an extremely successful generative
delight project because of the platform
that I built it on
I built it on glitch which is a platform
that basically encourages collaboration
and remixes if you haven't seen it
before this is it it's basically a
really fun and awesome code editor in
your browser it lets you like watch the
output whatever but in particular it
tries to like build this community
around projects and it encourages remix
think of people's projects so people so
I tend to ride my projects in a way
where people can look at the code really
easily and like change it if they want
to and to miri mixing is the premise of
generative art you take something and
you regenerate it in a way that's like
makes sense to you so what what are not
happening with moji garden is that
people took it and they started making
their own garde gardens with it they
remixed it into Hedgehog Gardens where
only hedgehogs and no other animals were
invited into really scary deserts that
had scorpions and spiders and like a lot
of fires because that was a snack they
made into a sky because San Francisco
has a lot of clouds and sometimes you
want to see a whole bunch of Suns in the
sky
and they made that they also made void
escapes which is my favorite I don't
know what it means and I love it
it's like absolutely goth it's the gothy
a-- sting i've seen done with javascript
sometimes you get like ominous eyeballs
and labels that say that the end is near
and clocks and i love it like if I could
just have this projected in my house all
the time I would it's brilliant
Audrey made this fantastic so the
surprise here in this project wasn't
what I made which wasn't generative
delight it was glitch the platform made
a generative because the thing about art
or really anything is that we don't make
it into a void we live in this weird
online world where everything is online
happening all the time everywhere at
once
and the code that we use the devices
that we distributed on the way the way
we put it out there all of these shape
the end result of what you're making and
in here glitch shaped my project and it
was wonderful and it wouldn't have been
a successful project if glitch didn't
exist this isn't a weird thing like if
you think about like an oil painter if
you take away his oil they're their oil
paints and you give them like thumbtacks
they're still going to produce art it's
just going to be very different that
they were going that the thing that
we're going to produce with oil
paintings the same is gonna happen if
you know I give you only a row of pixels
and you have to produce art with it you
you will do it it's just gonna look
different because everything that we
rely on is important for creativity and
this is absolutely true of code as well
the reason why emoji garden was so easy
to remix is because of specific code
decisions that I made and I'm gonna tell
you a little bit about this in a second
because if you want to build visual
things you should use visual libraries
and things that help you with it think
of something like processing.js it's a
library that's literally built for you
know visual things so if you want to
build something visual processing will
help you with it if you want to build
something visually probably not gonna
reach for C++ unless you're you like
pain and memory leaks that's not to say
that you can't produce art with C++ you
absolutely can like there is wonderful
WebGL [ __ ] like WebGL got Open GL
shaders and stuff in games and you know
every video game in my opinion is art
it's just going to be harder because all
of this time that you have to spend you
know looking for pointers checking to
see if you've shot yourself in the foot
when you're managing your memory and all
of that stuff that's less time that you
have to be creative and to paint things
on the screen which was the thing that
you originally wanted to do you wanted
to like give the user some pixels so
emoji garden uses this library called
tracer ejs and tracer jeaious is built
by kate compton for procedure art and
it's a super simple library that i want
to show you how it works because without
it emoji garden wouldn't have been
possible
so in tracery jsut basically define your
world as a grid of available tokens so
here i think i picked em for either
Monica or a model I don't remember it
was like late at night before visitor
and as for snacks and this is what
basically every garden looks like and I
just randomize where these go I like
Rolla dice so I tell tracery that this
is my pattern and then I also tell it
what values you can put in so I give it
like a set of tokens the model can be
cactuses and empty spaces the visitors
can be like a mouse and a de life a
little hot Hedgehog and then you paste
you give these two things at tracery and
then tracery basically goes token for
token and picks a random value from the
world that's all it does until it fills
the entire grid this isn't hard like I
could have written this for loop I'm
competent at writing for loops I could
have done this it's like for loops and
like JavaScript random numbers which
while weird are not that hard but I did
and I used a library that was made to
help me with this because that means
that if somebody wanted to remix this
project they didn't have to know or read
my for loops and like weird functions
that I declared all they had to do was
change the values of these tokens in the
world just change those like that world
object and everything else would get
regenerated after they want like how
they won and and this is why a lot of
people that weren't even programmers
managed to like take emoji guardant and
make their own gardens out of it and it
was really great and that's what made a
you know delightful to think about
tracer is that it's a serious libraries
built by a serious person for serious
things people use it to generate levels
and video games or poems or stories or
anything that you want people also use
it to make a grid of ominous eyeballs
and doomsday clocks and I think that's a
really important thing because I think
about art is that you don't have to get
it somebody out there is going to get it
and it's fine if you don't get it
I don't get Roy Lichtenstein that
doesn't stop the MoMA from putting
pictures like his paintings in in their
museum so if we agree that making making
things is objectively good then we
should also agree that helping people
make these things is also objective
really good and in particular it's
important so when I came to this
conclusion I was like oh [ __ ] this is
what I this is what I want to work like
this is what I want to get paid for
helping people build sillier artsy
creative things and that's how I ended
up working on magenta which is the team
that I work on now so budget is a team
of researchers in a couple of Engineers
and a friend and engineering me and the
researchers are super smart and
brilliant and do machine learning
research where they create these like
brilliant models that are able to
generate music and then I come in and I
try to make a little JavaScript
delightful interaction with it so that
other people take these models and
actually do useful things with them so
the role of these team this team is to
explore the role of machine learning in
the creative process not replace the
creative process but sort of interact
with it and see how we can help artists
musicians and creators use machine
learning to like make awesome [ __ ] with
it because for better for worse machine
learning is like the hot new [ __ ] right
now is a word that's being thrown around
everywhere from like selling you better
ads to selling me shoes on Instagram to
cancer cells to self-driving cars to
anything you want so why shouldn't it
help us with music and art why is that a
lesser area that we shouldn't be
focusing on so before we even like to
talk about music and art I want to give
you like the two-second introduction to
machine learning because if you haven't
heard of it I don't want you to like
feel bad because machine learning is
really not that special it's like a
glorified function we know functions
we've been writing algorithms and
functions for like all of our
professional life a classic algorithm or
function is to double a number this
one's an easy one you put in a number
you double it and that's what our
function looks like for any X we can
double it we can have more complicated
function
our algorithms like what would be the
function to get from here to the closest
kaya toast place there was like
algorithms for this like bellman-ford or
like better ones cuz bellman-ford is
from like 30 years ago and it probably
doesn't actually work with maps but we
have this we can do this is not super
hard but we have like functions that we
don't really know how to write like how
would you write a function to decide if
something's a dog or a cat so if I put
in a dog it says dog and if I put in a
cat it says cat and it does so reliably
so if I put in a fancier kind of cat it
still knows that it's a cat and if I put
like a sausage dog it tells me it's a
dog and not a sausage but I don't know
how to write that
like what is a cat is like an
existentialist crisis in my life because
I live with a cat like what is a cat is
it a lump of fur that just sits there
and judges can I write that in binary no
can I write that in JavaScript
absolutely no you can start thinking
about heuristics like what makes a dog
maybe if it has like media like beady
black eyes and like a snout but no
whiskers that's a dog but if it has
whiskers it's a cat but there's dogs
that have whiskers and there's cats that
look like dogs and there's blueberry
muffins that look like dogs so that is
just not gonna fly right that's not a
function that we know how to write
there's if you google this you're gonna
get like tons of like dogs that look
like foods because these are that's what
we do if we write functions so that's
what machine learning comes into play
where she learning is just a different
way of writing these functions so that
it figures out what that function is by
just feeding it examples I don't need to
know what makes a dog dog I just need to
give it enough examples of a dog so that
if it sees any dog it goes yep that's a
dog because that's what we really do as
humans we've seen a lot of dogs in the
world that's how we know what a dog is
so the way we train these models and
what I mean by model I mean this
function whenever you hear a machine
learning person be like I use the model
to predict they just mean what is the
output of the function so to train this
model we basically feed it by hand
labeled examples so we know this is a
dog and we know this is a cat so we fit
it feet on a picture of a dog where we
know what the answer is
but we don't tell it we're tricking the
model because we're cruel like that it's
like those people who are pushing those
robots like the you know the robots that
look like dogs and they're like putting
all these videos of like look at this
dog falling over and getting up they're
the first to die in the robot apocalypse
not us we are nice we're feeding at
pictures of dogs so we put in this
picture of a dog and we're like hey
model what is it and the model doesn't
know at this point so he goes is it a
cat and you're like oh that's silly this
is a dog and then you give it a picture
of a cat and the model goes I don't know
is this a cat here's like very good
model you're doing great that is a cat
and then you do this a million times and
I'm not kidding about this I literally
mean like the data sets have a million
data points of dogs and cats and the
model looks at it over and over and over
again until it goes listen I think I got
it I most of the time I don't get this
wrong and I think I know it so then when
you show it a picture of a dog it goes
yes it's a dog and you're like
absolutely you did it of course this
depends on like what kind of data you're
putting and if you're only putting in
pictures of cats and golden retrievers
machine learning isn't magic this
function isn't magic if you show it a
picture of a beagle but you've only
trained in golden retrievers it's not
going to know this as a dog it's
probably gonna flip a coin this is how
we get racist algorithms and though in
the world by the way it's because we
only feed at pictures of white people
and then we like ask it to categorize a
black person and it goes monkey because
it hasn't seen a black person because
you're a terrible engineer and what are
you doing with that data this makes me
really angry so training data is really
important so this is how he trying to
machine learning models see it's done
behind the scenes it's like really
complicated but it doesn't matter
because what we need to understand
machine learning is like how you know
the basics of it and how it works so
machine learning hasn't isn't
particularly new I think like the first
neural networks that were like in the
60s and the 70s we've had quite a long
time with them but they haven't exploded
to like five or ten years ago really
five years ago because we used to suck a
lot in machine learning our computers
were really slow we didn't have GPUs so
we were really bad at doing matrix math
machine learning is all matrix math
nowadays and in particular we didn't
have any of these training data sets
like the cats and the dogs that I showed
you we didn't have a million data points
and if we did they were really pixelated
so we weren't really able to like
generate really good cats or dogs
so we
really good at this because the methods
got better the algorithms got better
GPUs are like powerful and we've
sacrificed a lot of goats and firstborn
and now we have like incredibly fast
computers and it's great so because
we're really good at this we are so
really good at generative model so the
model that I showed you before is called
a classifier what it's really good at is
basically labeling data it looks at a
cat and goes yes it's a cat a generative
model is something that without any
input generates something so for example
it would be able to generate cats and
dogs that look like the cats and dogs
and the data set but aren't memorized
the joy just like them but not exactly
the same and we've got a really good at
these two with with a model called again
a general general address all your
network which is notably really good at
generating faces that don't exist it's
wildly creepy this this is a set of
websites that used to exist that got
taken down because holding servers up is
hard but none of these people are real
these people don't exist in real life
these people are the output of a machine
learning algorithm that is really really
really good at generating believable
faces and if you want to know about how
this works come chat with me later it's
actually really interesting but this is
the thing that we're really good at
we're really good at generating cats
that don't exist and sometimes they have
like weird artifacts like the one on the
unicorn side of the stage but they're
still like very believable cats we can
generate rooms that don't exist oh all
of these by the way are because for
better or for worse these are the
datasets that we have so like machine
learning researchers are like well the
data sets that I have are people cats
and Airbnb is so let's do it but none of
these rooms again exist like this is a
completely like a machine learning
algorithm dreamed up this bedroom that
now exists and is going for like
probably a billion pounds in London but
we're not just good at like images we're
also in the in recent time became really
good at music so a transformer is a
different kind of model that's usually
used for language but music is a little
bit like language so now we're able to
generate things that sound like this
[Music]
and it goes on forever because the model
doesn't know how to end songs that's
based on research by like one of my
coworker is called Anna Huang and she's
brilliant as she's going to solve music
so it's really great we're able to like
generate music but what does that mean
to a musician or to an artist because I
don't want somebody to generate music
for me I want them to generate music
with me I want it to be a really smart
instrument because we live in this world
were like technologies everywhere my
kitchen faucet is literally
voice-activated I can tell it to
dispense me a cup of water it's helpful
sometimes not helpful most of the time
but I play music in the same way that I
did 15 years ago I have a physical piano
and I sit at it and I'm still really bad
at composing and I make a lot of
mistakes and nobody tells me how to fix
these mistakes and what I want in the
world are these better weirder more
surprising more inspiring more
configurable instruments and interfaces
to make music that can help me make
better music because that's what I want
to do interfaces like this this is a
demo made by taro using one of the
magenta models so he basically generates
a whole bunch of melodies with one of
our models and then as you go up and
down the key that that melody is in and
as you go left to right the melody
changes so with this instrument you can
make things like this
[Music]
that's a good song we also had something
like the Google Doodle that he may have
seen for box birthday like about a month
ago where there was this little app that
lets you enter a melody and it would
like harmonize with you and make a box
sounding for voice Corral and this was a
fun little game but we also explored
what it would look like if we're going
to build like a fuller instrument for
somebody to compose with so I built this
like side app for it where you basically
get to like interact with a model more
so you get to like draw a little melody
which you might recognize as the legal
version of seven nation army and then we
can ask the model to like fill in this
melody and give us the other three
voices
but then we can also play with like
whatever attributes the model exposes so
temperature is a thing that and machine
learning sort of means a randomness so
if I decrease the temperature sort of
like the entropy of it it's conservative
or I can crank up the temperature and
make it like super random and it's going
to put a lot of like arbitrary notes in
there they don't really match and make
Bach like shudder
[Music]
and at this point like everything is
configurable you can start like erasing
some of the notes asking the model to
like infill a particular section maybe
throw away a whole bunch of things and
like try to play with it and compose in
this app and at the end you can download
the MIDI and it's your MIDI you've
composed a new melody with it and these
are the kind of things that we want to
build we can also build weird interfaces
where we figured out there's a model one
of our nerve residents built where you
summarize 88 keys on a piano to eight so
rather than playing the whole piano you
can play eight of them
[Music]
and you're really prolific and great and
you might be like well that's silly what
applications do you have of this but the
Flaming Lips use this at Google i/o for
their concert but rather than playing
eight buttons they played fruit we
connected those eight buttons to a Miki
Miki and then as they were playing the
fruit the model would like make the next
correct node and like it was a really
fun interactive thing we've also built a
set of Ableton plugins because it turns
out music musicians live in Ableton so
we were like well what it would look
like if you put these machine learning
models in Ableton would that be useful
and you can go read about them because
I'm already gonna be five minutes over
time and we can do this with art - we
don't just do it with music
we're just most of us are musicians less
artists nobody cares about me we have
models that have looked at people
sketching things so they're really good
at drawing cats like a million people
draw cats so I build this silly thing
where you start drawing a cat and then
the model continues it for you and then
you can draw a whole bunch of different
animals like a crab or a truck that's
gonna be off-screen it has wheels
thank you swear or a whale and this
isn't art I understand this is an art
when I said that I have a problem with
the word art I understand fully that you
should judge this this is not art but it
doesn't mean he can't be first of all
kids love the [ __ ] out of this and
second of all if you spend time like
putting a model that also understands
painting and stuff like that you can
start making believable things with this
the things that we make and on the
magenta team isn't like products that we
make money out of we make models and
then experiences so that people can use
them and you can make money out of it
and the thing about all of the demos
that I showed you literally all of them
is that they're all done in JavaScript
we have a library it's open source it's
called magenta Jas and it's built on top
of tensorflow J's in such a way that you
can use all of this machine learning
without having to know what machine
learning is the models are pre-trained
the api's are super simple so that you
can take them and just make whatever
your heart desires and it's really easy
that spinners the incredible spinners
the way those random melodies were
generated
is with this model called music VA
that's good at generating fairly robotic
sounding music let's be very honest so
you create a model and then you ask it
to give you a sample and this gives you
back a sequence which is a lot like MIDI
is just like an object it looks like
MIDI and then you can create a player
which wraps tone jeaious because making
web audio and the browser in 2019 is
actually still horrifyingly hard and you
should never do that so the player does
all of that heavy lifting for you and
then you'd give it the sequence and you
go players start and then you can hear
it in a synthesizer or a piano or
whatever you want and I'm not like
pulling your leg here it's literally
like four lines of code to generate
infinitely sounding melodies maybe you
want to put that into the Bach chorale
you can take the sequence that again the
robots generated for you
you can create the other model called
coconut which is the one that does the
Bach infilling and then you can ask it
to infilled that sequence and it gives
you back a four voice sequence or a
chorale and then you can again pass that
to the player and go play or play me
this and this is exactly how you you you
generate all of those Corral's in the
demo that I showed you the piano genie
with a fort live with the eight buttons
super similar you create the model you
ask you you tell you that you've pressed
a button and like how random you want
the output to be and it gives you the
next note over and over and over again
as you're playing it and the reason why
we work on this library is because we
really believe that code should never
hold back art if that API looks
surprisingly easy it's not a random it's
a deliberate decision because when we're
a meeting with musicians it turns out
musicians don't really know how to
install Python and Python dependencies
and get our Python code that would take
like 17 command-line parameters to work
and then we'll give you like a MIDI file
in your temp directory you just don't
really know how to do this they used
Ableton and we want people to build
tools for musicians because that's the
people that we want to interact with
artists and creators not just like
engineers who really want to write
snakes on their computer snakes is what
I call Python feel free to take that one
spiders is what I call JavaScript your
future take that one too and this makes
sense if you think of your favorite
painter or like artist the guy's one of
mine did God didn't make his own pastels
he bought them from Cinelli which was a
man who spent his entire life making
chalk pastels he couldn't draw worth
[ __ ] and they got couldn't make his own
pastels
yo-yo ma doesn't build his own cellos he
like buys them from people who made them
in the 1600s the artists don't shouldn't
make the tools to make the art they're
there to make the art itself
because at the end of the day the medium
influences how the message is perceived
this is a quote by Marshall McLuhan who
is a Canadian go Canada but it's trying
to tell you that like models don't exist
in a void they exist in like this
artistic environment that we live in and
how we deliver these models to people
and what you do with the models is the
thing that messes that matters that is
the medium so I want to show you I'm
going to end with like these examples of
a couple of art installations remember
the creepy generated images of people
that don't exist that we're really good
at Mario Clingerman has an art
installation has several art
installations actually that uses that
algorithm to generate infinitely many
portraits so as you come into this room
these paintings of people just get
generated for ever and ever and you can
look at them the thing about this
installation is that it wasn't possible
five years ago it wouldn't have been
possible without these machine learning
algorithm the algorithms that we have
today a painter is not able to generate
infinitely many portraits we can count
to infinity it's like a lot it takes a
bunch of time so this is a way that we
can use machine learning in art and
still maintain that integrity of art
this is one of my favorite things that
I've ever seen in my life it's an art
installation called peeping skulls by
Robbie Barrett and Ronon Burroughs same
name different people Robbie Barrett is
an artist it is a lot of art with
artificial intelligence and Ronon
Barrett is an oil painter so they got
together and based on running Barrett's
painting style
Robbie trained a model to generate
skulls that look like Ronon would have
painted them and they actually exhibited
this as an installation next to physical
paintings of these skulls in a museum
and what happens in this installation is
that he walk up to it and then you look
and it tells you what's about to happen
you're going to get generated a random
skull that looks like a run and Barrett
oil painting this is this one and you
get to look at it for five to ten
seconds
and then it disappears forever and it's
been marked in the algorithm machine
learning algorithm so that I can never
get generated again if the out of the
machine learning algorithm tries to
generate this again if the model does it
it's going to try to generate another
one this was your skull and your skull
alone and in this weird Instagram world
where you post like our entire lives two
stories this is like an amazing
commentary about this intimacy of this
art experiments where we can all
experiment like we can all live this
experiment but never share what we
actually saw and I think this is
fantastic there's this great quote from
Brian Eno that says that what you now
find weird ugly uncomfortable and nasty
about a new medium will surely become
its signature
the distorted guitar sound is the sound
of something too loud for the medium
supposed to carry it everything that you
love in the world right now has at one
point been judged and looked down by
people probably white men from weird
music - Impressionism - cubism -
assembling your own Swedish chairs in
your living room and making art with AI
and math and algorithms isn't new and
maybe feels uncomfortable now but that
doesn't mean we shouldn't encourage it
to grow because I think it's got great
opportunities and I think this means
that a lot of us should start making
really serious things so that you know
somewhere out there somebody can make a
random painting of a skull that exists
for five seconds and then it disappears
forever
thank you